okay so welcome back to the afternoon
session
our speaker now is aditi raghunathan
she's a postdoc here at berkeley
and moving soon to cmu
and she will talk about understanding
the robustness of deep learning
all right
uh hi everyone i'm aditi and thanks to
the organizers for inviting me
so i'm quite literally
in by the definition moving to cmu so if
there's anything that doesn't make sense
in the slides or what i say it's all
because of the fact that i'm moving
um
okay so when we you know think about
robustness it's like a question that a
lot of people are thinking about these
days and the typical story that we have
in mind is you know when we are thinking
about using ml in safety critical
applications like self-driving cars it's
very promising but like sometimes we
find issues happen for example in this
incident a woman was killed because
among other issues if we didn't record
or the model didn't recognize a
pedestrian who was jaywalking because it
was only trained on pedestrians at
crosswalks
and then maybe a example that hit closer
to home now is that you want to train on
certain weather conditions but you want
it to work all the time especially in
unpredictable weather and so on
so this is the usual
so this is the usual story uh when you
think about robustness and of course
this is really important when we think
about deploying systems in real world
applications
but in this talk i kind of wanted to say
why i think robustness is interesting
and shares or shared some important
perspectives on machine learning more
generally and so this is very hand wavy
but this is kind of the way i think
about it
um what dictates a model's predictions
so at the end of the day there are two
components that kind of come together
one is the training data that you give
the model and then there's this you know
inductive bias or like the rest of the
stuff which is basically your
architecture how you initialize the
network what does gradient descent do
and so on which says how this training
data actually is used to make the
predictions
and we need to think about both of these
together usually
but i think robustness which basically
looks at the performance on a different
distribution as a training distribution
could actually be quite interesting
because you know by the nature of
robustness you're kind of reducing the
effect of training data on the model's
predictions and you can really see a
little bit more of what the inductive
buyers or this nurture component is
because if you look at predictions
outside or very close to the training
data all models might really be doing
the same but by really looking things
outside you're stress testing and seeing
like what exactly is this nurture the
inductive bias component oh no i
switched the two what's the nature of
this uh component
and this one i'll try to like share some
of these observations and perspectives
um you know in this talk
um i had the you know i could look at
the rest of the program because my talk
was tbd to very late and so i saw that
most of the talks were on supervised
learning so i thought it might be
interesting to talk about a setting that
is gaining quite some prominence lately
on transfer learning or pre-training or
you know foundation models or whatever
so i'll talk a little bit about that
first and then in the end mention
various results and supervised learning
roughly along the same format of seeing
what interesting things can we learn
about how these models learn when we
actually examine the robustness or the
performance of these models outside this
iid setting
and the way i'll try to organize um in
each of these settings the kind of
results is so we'll start with some
empirical observations about how these
models perform in practice and typically
we'll try to find something that's
interesting or un you know that's a
little bit unintuitive and try to
capture that in a theory setting
and the hope is that by writing down
some math and actually being able to
prove something in a stylized setting we
actually gained some intuition or
understanding of what is going on or
what captures some of these empirical
observations
and really the goal standard would be
that we use this theory or the inside to
come up with some useful solution now
because we are in a stylized setting we
should be able to manipulate things and
move them around and like get a solution
that makes sense and again like really
it would be cool if we can translate
this theory solution into something in
practice as well this is kind of what
we'll hope to do or like what i hope to
do in most of the projects and i'll try
to you know keep this outline for the
talk as well
so the idea is that this theory setting
captures some intuition or understanding
and like we can actually test this
intuition or understanding by seeing
whether we can change the training
method or like something in a way that
actually fixes or you know shows
empirical observations that would be
predicted by our theory
so with that i'll jump right into the
first part of the talk on transfer
learning and robustness
so here's the general pre-training setup
and this is a figure that i've adapted
from bhumasani at all so the idea in
pre-training is that you first you have
like multiple steps in the process so in
the first step you do this what is
called pre-training where you collect a
lot of diverse data from the wild and so
you don't think too carefully on what
exactly this data is or how it's related
to the final task you just collect
diverse data from the wild and do kind
of a pre-training
and use that to get something called a
pre-trained model
and once we have this pre-trained model
now we do our usual machine learning
setting or where we have some training
data that is relevant to the task we
care about and then we adapt this
pre-trained model on this training data
and you can do multiple tasks and so
depending on which task or which
distribution you are in you collect
appropriate training data and you
specialize this pre-training model to
that narrow distribution
so in a supervised learning you would
typically only do step two and you'll
start with a random initialization but
instead here what we're doing is we're
starting with this pre-trained
initialization and then using the
training data that is specific to the
task we care about and trying to adapt
this model to work well on whichever
task we choose to
okay so why should we think about
pre-training
and one example that i think is pretty
compelling is say we want to do
satellite remote sensing so the idea is
that we have satellite images of
different regions and we want to use
that to tell us what is happening in
that region and that's a way to assess
what is the development happening in
different places
but the challenge here is that we
typically only have training data from
certain regions which is like typically
we get more annotators we have more
information about what's going on and
that's kind of not the point of the task
like actually when we want to use ml as
a case where now we want to generalize
to a setting where we don't have as much
data for example in africa
so now if we just do the typical machine
learning the supervised learning what
you do is you start with a random model
initialization and then you would train
it on this in distribution training data
which is north america
and
unfortunately
and unfortunately because models are
typically not robust they don't do very
well on this new distribution africa
that is slightly far from this training
data of north america and so the the
whole reason we wanted to do this in the
first place which is of like you know
using ml in places where we don't have
annotation kind of doesn't really work
but maybe this is like not that
unexpected because well the model has
never seen any data from africa has no
information of what to do so maybe we
shouldn't expect this to work and so the
idea in pre-training is that now let's
actually train on diverse data like it
need not be annotated it could be
unlabeled but like in the process you've
hopefully given data from a lot of
different geographic locations so at
least the model has some notion of like
what data from africa looks like but not
with explicit annotations
there is some information here and now
let's try to retain that information and
then add on like explicit annotation the
tasks that we care about
and what we find is actually it is true
that doing some kind of pre-training
does enable better performance on out of
distribution settings like africa here
because this the fact that you've
trained on such diverse things in the
beginning enables the model to actually
generalize better to a distribution
that's unseen
in this particular adaptation stage
so especially for someone like me who
works on robustness i think i find uh
pre-training quite interesting because
it really is one of the most promising
ways to actually improve robustness
yeah i guess just to summarize yeah
sorry basically
in the first stage
what is being fitted so what is free
training okay um i should have had a
slide on that but okay the usual you
consider you
try to create different ways of
utilizing the data so one thing is just
do a generative process so like try to
generate the data itself so you can
learn a generative model that generates
the kind of data that you see and so
this model typically will like do it in
a way that actually incorporates
structured information about these data
sets so for example if you look at
images you don't need to know exactly
what the task is but there are certain
things of the image that are important
like what's the object what's the shape
like what kind of backgrounds is it
typically found in for example if it's a
bottle it has a particular shape and and
all of that so that information can
actually be dispelled even without
labels because it sees a lot of data
reduction you could think of it as a
dimensionality reduction there are other
ways that people do pre-training which
is you know you can incorporate um one
thing that's called contrastive learning
which is you like for example you know
that cert like rotations preserve the
object but or like cropping preserves so
you learn a representation that is
invariant to like cropping or rotation
on this unlabeled data and somehow this
representation like dimensional
reduction is better the other thing you
could do is like mask out certain parts
of the image and try to regenerate it
which is kind of like denoising auto
encoders so you can regularize it in a
certain way that actually enables it to
capture the right information in the
representations and because of that like
maybe if you have trained on data from
north america and africa it kind of
disentangles it in a way that captures
some structure that is more general than
if you're only trained on data from
north america so that's the goal but
again all of this is informal and we
have no sense of you know proof or
theory that any of this is like actually
happening
um any other questions
okay
so just to summarize so like in order
like i said like vaguely you could think
that pre-training incorporates some
information that is potentially more
diverse than what just happens if you
had a narrow label set
and this is uh typically improves in
distribution performance but it
substantially improves out of
distribution performance and you know
it's probably one of the most reliable
methods that we have today to improve
robustness across several natural shifts
so in some way it's not great because
it's all it's saying is that you train
on more data it works better but on like
robustness but it's kind of the only
thing that actually works when you don't
have any when you have these natural
shifts that you don't really know what's
happening
okay
so given that it makes sense to use this
notion of pre-training that is of being
able to train on diverse and label data
how do we actually use pre-trained
models and that's kind of going to be
the focus of this talk
so how do we leverage this information
that's contained in pretend models
so too popular so first i'll discuss two
popular methods and then we'll use that
as a way to think about what we should
be doing
so one idea is what people typically
call fine tuning which is you start with
this initialization and then you have so
for example you could have like features
now you add a linear head that looks at
these features and gives a label and
then now you back propagate you randomly
initialize the linear head you
initialize the rest of the model to be
what pre-training gave you and then you
uh do a few gradient updates on this in
distribution training data with like
cross entropy laws
so that's the usual fine tuning which is
basically you've replaced your random
initialization with this pre-trend
initialization and you run a few steps
of grading this and rather than running
many steps so that you don't lose all
this information
so that's
one method of fine tuning
and the other method is that you know
maybe we shouldn't change these
representations at all and especially
people think of this as a way to do
cheaper fine tuning so you don't even
change these models you don't have to
store them in memory and pass gradients
and all that you just use these
representations on its own keep these
fixed and just learn the linear head
and that's called linear
so these are like two most popular
methods of using pre-trained models that
are considered in literature one of them
updates everything one of them updates
only the linear head and this is
typically known to be more memory
efficient but the other one is supposed
to work better
okay
so what is the challenge in trying to
think about what is the right way to
fine tune or use these models because
there are really several moving pieces
in addition to what we're usually used
to so usually we have just the model
architecture and your one training
distribution
but now you have to think about the
pre-training distribution the
pre-training loss or the procedure and
then we need to think of this downstream
or adaptation distribution and also like
what is the procedure so there are all
of these things that now all interact
together in deciding what's your final
performance
so for the purposes of this talk we'll
like not worry about these four
components and really only focus on this
adaptation procedure for example like
linear probing and fine tuning are two
different adaptation procedures and so
we'll think about what is the right
adaptation procedure we should be using
okay so
i'll start off with some empirical
empirical observations
so i know we all just got back from
lunch so this is going to you know try
to be a little interactive in this part
so just to summarize again so we are
comparing two process procedures one is
fine tuning where everything is
propagated and linear probing where
everything is fixed except the linear
head
okay so
um let's look at this data set breeds
which is a you know quite an interesting
data set for studying robustness
so the task is to classify and into
animal categories
and we create a district or like they
created distribution shift in the
following way
so there's one subset of image net
hierarchy um
and so you like take the root and then
you have two sub trees so one of them is
train and one of them is test so they're
all the same animal but like different
subs subtypes of that animal and that's
how you split uh these data sets
and the pretend model we're using is
moco v2 which has seen unlabeled
imagenet images that have seen all these
images so it has seen unlabeled versions
of the train and test and so that's the
pre-trained model we'll be using and so
we want to see which method does what
here
so
by show of hands do you think if we
you know look okay so these are the in
distribution performances so just to get
around the same page if you train from
scratch you get 92 but if you did list
um pre-training you already see some
boosts because you have trained on more
diverse data which has kind of uh that
helps and um so linear probing gets some
amount and then fine tuning further
improves the
performance because you're training all
the parameters and not really just a few
parameters
so this is what indistribution
performance looks like
so now let's now try to see what happens
out of distribution
so on scratch gives 58 so there's you
know obviously a drop which is what
we're typically used to when we think
about robustness
so do you think linear probing that
allowed us to start from a pre-trained
model would actually improve performance
over scratch out of distribution as well
or not so by show of hands how many
people think that linear probing would
do better
out of distribution
i guess most people okay and you got it
right yes it does better
so you see there's actually quite a bit
of boost just because you've used
pre-trained models that have seen this
diverse unlabeled data
so now let's look at the other rules so
do you think linear probing does better
than fine-tuning order of distribution
so
notice that in distribution linear
probing did worse then fine-tuning
so what do you think is going to happen
out of distribution
so how many people think linear
programming would do better than
fine-tuning out of distribution
sure fans okay so most people think so
and oh no
this is wrong
my slides are wrong yeah like i said i
knew there were going to be some typos
so okay um
so yes you got it right
um so yes it does so surprisingly the
linear probing does worse in
distribution but it does better out of
distribution and this is actually kind
of surprising because if you look at the
literature on natural robustness these
days there's a little bit of a narrative
that improving performance in
distribution improves performance out of
distribution as well but here we see
there's actually a bit of a flip that
something that we typically do without
thinking which is fine tuning it seems
to be typically better but it does
actually worse out of distribution
okay so let's look at another data set
now
so let's look at another data set so
this is cfr 10.1
and the task is to class i most people
have probably worked with c410 there are
10 categories we want to classify images
and so this test distribution which is
the out of distribution it's like a near
replication of the pipeline done by rect
at all and so they just collected a new
seafart and data set with the same
protocol but using different unlabeled
images to start with
and again the pre-trained model is now
imagenet which is a much larger data set
so by free training you're seeing a much
larger amount of data than uh just the
original c410
so i'll repeat the quiz and there's i'm
i'm also like oh what's going to happen
on my slide so yeah so what do you think
is gonna so okay i removed from scratch
because you know quite it's quite clear
it does better than scratch both linear
probing and fine tuning
let's go back to linear probing versus
fine tuning so how many people think
that in this data set linear probing
does better than fine-tuning ort
few people okay um and the answer is no
yeah i got it right so the answer is no
so here surprisingly for this data set
like fine tuning does still better
and so what is different is that in this
data set this the distribution shift is
really small because they've really
really tried to keep the distributions
closed and you know like there are some
differences in how it was collected but
in general the test distribution shift
for 10.1 is much closer to c410 than in
the previous breed setting where you
actually like had different
subcategories and so in that case linear
probing actually did better out of
distribution but here we find that
actually fine tuning that's better
yeah
oh sorry thanks yeah um how does this
compare to for example training like the
last linear layer as well as the last
convolutional layer because i think
that's like
supposedly like people think that maybe
that combines the best of both worlds so
i'll at the end of the talk we'll talk
about combining best of both but the
particular method that you said if i
remember correctly we tried it on a few
data sets like we varied the number of
layers that are trained and typically
interpolates in performance between
linear probing and fine tuning so if
you're in this situation then it will do
better than linear propane but not as
good as fine tuning and the previous
case will be better than fine feeling
but not as good as we have all
right i don't have numbers but they
would be in the high 90s like people
have tried that and like if there is no
distribution mismatch like they do just
as well so maybe you see for 10.1 i
think that it might be slightly harder
than a c front time so acres is a little
lower for the same amount of data but in
the debris is like you get the same
performance as training uh in
distribution so if there is no shift
then performance is quite good so it's
not like the task is inherently harder
that's what they're asking yeah what's
the worst the random prediction meant
like
okay so to summarize so you know in this
small game what we found is that it's
like a very like you know it's not clear
which method does better but you know
when you look at an average of our 10
data sets what we find is um the common
wisdom is that we should do fine tuning
if you can and people typically only
reserve linear probing if they're memory
constrained and but actually we find
that in distribution yes that is the
case but out of distribution the story
is more nuanced and you know occurs
across these 10 distributions we found
the reverse trend um
so yeah i think and like yeah eight of
the ten data sets actually linear for
being performed better and on a few data
sets like the c flat 10.1 example it
didn't do yeah i wonder did you try to
restrict uh how far away you can go in
fine tuning from
the point from which you find yourself
or using small learning shadow or using
some clipping of the gradients or
something yeah so um one thing that you
could do is like doing a like l2
regularization towards the initial
um for initialization or something so
people have tried things like that and
it does improve over fine tuning a
little bit but not as much as linear
propane but did you check also your
results how far away your final weights
from the tv show when you started
so we'll get into that a little bit like
we did yeah so we'll talk about how to
get the best of both and like you know
how does it compare and stuff yeah um
okay so hopefully this actually got
people interesting to think so i think i
remember that you know given the trend
that
these big companies are releasing big
models and like what should we do as
students and all of that so hopefully
this at least tells people that it's
very it's still pretty non-trivial and
unclear like how do we use these models
and hopefully there's still interesting
research and stuff that has to be
figured out yeah
yeah so in fine tuning you start with
the initialization but you change all
parameters we have graded updates but in
linear probing you keep your features
fixed that is like your last but one
layer is fixed and you only train a
medium layer on top um like you only
adapt that linear layer on your uh like
your test distribute like whatever like
adaptation distribution
um so here like some parameters are
fixed but as here all parameters can
change
but they all usually change i mean they
don't you don't train for like as many
steps as you typically do so it's still
it's still better than doing from
scratch even if you do find it
uh does it matter like a regime where
you're doing these experiments like are
they like in an over parameterized
machine where you have a more like
director for example
like perhaps
[Music]
the opposite thing if you operate in a
different region yes maybe more samples
yes so as you increase the number of
samples you have during evaluation the
effect does go down yeah so it is
important that we are in like a setting
of like limited data so in fact you
don't even have to do out of
distribution just in distribution itself
you will see a similar effect if you
restrict your samples enough so if i
take c for 10 but just take like say 500
1000 examples you'll still do somewhat
okay because of the pre-training but
then you'll see that actually like
linear probing will do better than
fine-tuning even out just normal iit as
well so but it is important that you're
in a regime you're more practical
and we'll see that in the theory as well
okay cool
um
so this is just to you know quickly
summarize so this common wisdom you know
we might want to question especially out
of distribution and of course this is
not always it typically happens when you
have high quality pre-trained features
so if your features are not very good
linear probing probably can't do very
well you know to start with and we
actually saw this so in moco v1 versus
v2 we see that in mocha v1 which is
worse linear probing doesn't do better
than fine tuning but when we use the
better pre-trained model linear probing
does better than fine tuning and of
course larger distribution shifts like
you know in the extreme where test and
train are the same then fine tuning does
well but as the shift becomes larger
like there's a tendency for linear
probing to do better
and so this kind of you know inspired us
to think really about like how do we
improve this downstream performance at
the very least we should be able to get
the best of both because that
information is contained in the model
okay so
uh so now we'll talk about the theory
setting
so
um you know transfer learning is not new
people have tried to study transfer
learning in the past but most of the
work on transfer learning only looks at
linear probing which happens to be a
convex problem
and in this work we really want to think
at least about fine tuning and linear
probing so we need to think about this
fine tuning which now makes things
non-convex because all these parameters
are changing and they all interact with
each other getting a non-convex
objective this is one typical challenge
that you know we again have to revisit
when we think about how do we analyze
this finding
and the other thing is uh it is the same
objective as training from scratch so we
still want to also capture that
fine-tuning does better than training
from scratch so just looking at the
usual objective is not enough and we
need to really think about the training
dynamics that were starting from
pre-training so we can't do for example
like the ntk kind of relaxation assuming
random initialization or something like
that because we really want to also
capture that we are in the pre-training
setting
so i think this is a pretty interesting
regime for theory analysis in general
and so hopefully more people are also
excited about like how do we capture
these analysis and in this talk and in
this work we do something pretty simple
but like already gives us something
interesting
um okay so here's the brief intuition
for the theory result
um so let's say this is what the
features look like so you have blue and
id and green and od so this is like a
toy this is not any real thing it's just
an illustration
so let's say that the features were good
such that you know you do end up
separating the crosses and circles
roughly in a direction the same for id
and overd but of course the domains are
also somewhat separated because they are
ultimately different data points and
without labels there's no reason that it
was collapsed
so let's assume this is what like a good
features look like
now what happens when we do fine tuning
so we first initialize a classifier
right so this could be this initial head
and the crucial thing here is that
when we're doing fine tuning we're
changing all parameters so we're going
to change the features as well as the
linear head together
so suppose we have this as the initial
head now when we take a gradient step
we're going to change the features so
let's to simplify let's assume we're
doing like alternations so let's see how
the features change to accommodate this
head the features will change that way
and now the head also will change and so
basically both of them are going to keep
changing
and because of that the features change
sorry
because of that the features are going
to change in a way to accommodate the
head while the head also changes
but in a simplistic case let's assume
that the features are separate enough
that your overd examples now because
they were not trained um there's no
reason for these features to change much
so these features don't change
so as a result what has happened is that
the head which was obtained for this
data set doesn't work as well out of
distribution because here the features
have changed and the head matches those
change features whereas our d nothing
has changed and now like whatever
information was initially captured in
the pretend information is kind of lost
in the process
does that like kind of intuition make
sense
so that's just because um i guess a
little bit of the over parametric
settings so like if we found this i mean
we tested this empirically as well but
this is just like an intuition that
let's assume there are different
subspace of the training data and so
like you're not basically never like
updating anything to do with that
representation
uh no like nothing is frozen here so you
assume that features can change but
you're assuming in this video this over
parameterized setting where there are no
gradients related to the points over d
because your training loss doesn't have
anything to do with these dimensions it
only has like a few dimensions
which is corresponding to your english
situation there's a little hand baby but
like basically you can think of this as
the old examples lying in different
subspace of your training data with
respect to the features for the features
that are getting against
um yeah
yeah the margin doesn't matter the
reason we have the small margin is
because you know i'll get to that but
it's about linear probing so at the end
of the day it's not like your features
are going to be great because they're
trained without any annotation on like
diverse data so it's not like the
features are going to be great so it's
probably something like this which is
why linear probing doesn't work well um
so yeah so we assume low margin just to
replicate the case where linear probing
doesn't work as well
so your features are not perfect so the
data might not be separable in the
future but yeah
yeah so but uh
yeah so basically if your data is far
enough out of distribution so for
example in like the breeds like do you
have all these different sub populations
and they're going to be in different
parts of the representation so you're
never going to get an upgrade with
respect to those parts that are not in
your training data when you just update
on the training laws
yeah that's a um that's a good question
so here it's like obviously stylized
that things are like totally disrupted
so maybe you won't do as many graded
updates so it will not change this much
so like you know maybe
maybe it'll be something in practice you
won't change you won't run too many
gradient steps so it's not going to be
totally corrupted
so you should still have some some uh it
like it might be something like so this
is a bad illustration but like basically
here it's like trying to be too extreme
but you can imagine that you run like a
few gradient steps your features do
change a little bit but it still
has more structure than if your features
were randomly initialized
because you're not like totally
overfitting to you're starting from a
representation that is capturing some
semantic and you change only a few times
or a little bit
yeah yeah
yeah if you run it forever then like you
know the sim that is going to be lost
and you you'll probably get back to the
training from scratch kind of a
situation but you typically run it for
much fewer steps so it's implicitly
regularized
yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you run it like for a long time
you end up overfitting anyways and you
lose information that you have yeah so
typically you do have to early stop if
you want to keep gains
yeah so how do you decide when to start
usually people have a validation set so
here like any validation that we have
done in any of the experiments was just
in distribution
so you know and like what linear probing
could why it could be doing better is
that
here you're not changing the features at
all and so you like would end up
learning a linear heads like looks like
this and so this would do better out of
distribution because the head is still
decent on these examples
but like you know one of you asked you
do end up because the features are not
perfect and you're only learning a
linear classifier if your features were
not linearly separable to begin with
there's not much that you could do so
you might end up doing worse in
distribution which is kind of what we
see in practice which is why typically
we do fine tuning because the features
are not perfect but in the process we
might you know affect the robust okay
so this is a summary like this idea of
feature distortion is that fine tuning
can lead to the feature distortion and
why that is is because features for in
distribution is when you're doing
updates on there the features will
change in sync with this linear head
that you're trying to learn and if
you're randomly in your head is
initialized very far then your fetus
might also end up changing a lot to
accommodate this linear head and od the
features change a little less or much
less because they're not trained on and
we did check this empirically so the the
id examples like if you look at the
representations and see the l2 distance
they change by an order of magnitude
larger than the change od so it is true
that you could roughly think of in this
over parameterized setting that the od
is like kind of unseen directions that
you don't get really gradients on when
you do this adaptation
and the result of this is that this head
can fit like so that can fit distorted
features that is totally fine if you
only care about indistribution
performance because as a together as a
unit they're still okay but in the
process you've started performing worse
on od examples that originally they were
more semantically related through the
features but now you lost that structure
because of the starting features
so this kind of captures uh what we saw
in practice of why linear probing does
better out of distribution despite doing
worse in distribution
um so you know to kind of uh
prove something about this we considered
the simplest setting that we could you
know try to replicate this result in so
we have linear two-layer linear networks
um so here's a figure so you have inputs
and you have a linear feature extractor
and then you have another linear head so
this is just to make analysis easy
and so your ground truth is
the product of these two so things are
still non-convex but it just doesn't
have the non-linearity in the
activations
and we use the square loss again it
makes life easier and so we
want to train models and evaluate them
on the squared loss
and just to recap in fine tuning we
update both these parameters this head
and the feature extractor
um whereas in linear probing b is like
fixed at whatever you get after
pre-training and only the head v is
updated
so if we were to contrast linear probing
and fine tuning we need at least two
layers for that reason because there are
two sets of parameters and this is kind
of the most like simplest setting we can
study
and in both cases this linear head again
in practice as well what is done is it's
randomly initialized
so these randomly initialized b is
initialized at a pre-training
um so the assumptions that we make are
that your pre-training is good and so if
you recall like you really see this
difference only when pre when the
pre-trained features are good and you
know empirically we saw that too so we
are in a setting where we can actually
bound how close b naught is to the b
star which is the optimal ground truth
and you know up to rotations we measure
how far they are and that's this
quantity epsilon so in this work we
assume that epsilon is small and we can
bound by epsilon how far your
pre-trained initialization is
and then the other simplifying
assumption we make which is kind of
common in transfer learning is that b
naught and b star have orthonormal rows
so i don't think this like you know we
could massage things to work even
otherwise but this doesn't change the
intuition much but makes calculations
easy
and the other thing we do is we assume
infinitesimally small learning rate so
we can
we can analyze the gradient flow
equations
so so those are the assumptions like
basically the most important thing is
that we are close and we make the
gradient flow assumption
so what does the data distribution look
like so this kind of answers some of the
questions that came up so we didn't want
to make any distributional assumptions
so we just made it as simple as we could
think of which is that we have a span of
training examples so we have n training
examples
and so s is the span so i don't remember
if i mentioned before but k is the
dimensionality of the features
so we are in this over parameterized
setting where n is or the dimensionality
of s
is less than d minus k
so what this really means is that there
has to be this notion of something that
is unseen in your adaptation process so
if your adaptation basically gave you
information about all parts of the
features that matter then we don't see
this effect fine tuning is still fine
but we want to really be in the setting
where the representation has more
parameters than the training data so
there are some unseen distributions or
tests and that's basically how we define
the test so we define test to be
something that has an invertible
covariance which means that the test
distribution or o d measures all
directions even though the training only
had a few directions and this kind of
crucially captures that we care about
adapting in a way that all directions
are preserved and not just the training
directions
and again we measure od by the same
squared error and yeah we make this
assumption od
that things are invertible just to say
that we want to find the worst case
directions which could have been
distorted
and we assume that your training regime
is such that you have fewer samples than
parameters
so yeah we are in the setting where
there are directions not seen like again
like
like most things that i've seen in
robustness actually they don't happen in
the under parameterized settings so if
you had fewer data points then you will
never really sorry fewer dimensions and
data points it's really hard to
construct a setting where one method
does better in distribution but does was
out of distribution unless there's a lot
of noise in your training data
but in the overparametric setting you
actually find these happen quite often
so what we prove in this paper which i'm
presenting a very simplified version
here is we can lower bound the o d error
of fine tuning
so we can say that because of this
feature distortion that happens we can
prove that the od error can never be
much lower because the od measures all
directions whereas your straining data
has only a few directions
so let me unpack these quantities
so we have this alpha by k part so alpha
basically measures what is the
interaction or the angle between
what is missing in the training data and
these are like the features that you
have
so if your training data is missing a
lot of important parts that actually
affect the features if alpha is larger
then we find that this lower bond
increases so this intuitively makes
sense that if your rows so basically b
naught already projects out some parts
because it's a dimensionality reduction
but we say if b naught doesn't like but
if you know in your training data you
still have directions that be not hasn't
projected out that are important but you
don't see it in the training data then
you have this kind of interaction that
causes issues
so alpha is a principal angle that it's
you know it's like a generalization of
the cosine angle and we find that that
is a quantity that determines the lower
bound on the o d performance
so the more b naught interacts with
missing directions the larger the od
error can get for the same reason that
we saw earlier because
your of the random initialization of the
head the two can interact and change
direct unseen directions in a way that
could be quite bad
distribution data yes but
in the previous case
so uh pre-training sees out of
distribution data which is why your b
naught is close to b star in all
directions so so if you look at the
assumption here um
yeah so b naught is close to b star in
like all directions so the l two norm
was small so they are close in every
direction because b naught which is what
is obtained after free training has seen
everything so it gets all directions
closed but now the question is can we
preserve these directions of b naught
when we do fine tuning or not and so in
the fine tuning process in the
adaptation process you don't see
everything so you have limited data
for which you have labels on but you're
still updating all parameters so that's
precisely why that quantity comes up
here which is you know b naught was
close to b star in all directions before
and but then now if you're going to
change that or mess that up because
there are directions that were unseen
but you still make updates on through
the head then you have this problem yeah
so k is the number of like missing
directions
of the representation
of which representation of the like b
naught
okay yes alphabet is basically the
fraction of like missing directions
yeah s for pen oh sorry i don't have it
here so s is the span of the training
data and s perpendicular basically the
odd terminal no uh like what is missing
in the training data so if there's a lot
of important directions of all of v
naught could be important because it
already has all directions so if there's
a lot of v naught that is actually
missing then you are in danger because
your features could be distorted in a
way that actually affects your
performance
yes you could think for purposes of this
talk you just assume green artist b star
so let's say you have perfect features
so b naught is b star but you might mess
up these perfect features by doing
gradient updates and the amount you mess
up depends on so you'll not mess up in
directions that you are getting data on
because you assume the data is good and
not noisy but you could mess up on
unseen directions and that is what this
s perpendicular measures so the more
unseen things interact would be not the
more your overdue
could you do fine tuning while enforcing
that the
features are still good on the yeah yeah
so that's kind of what we will get doing
yeah
sorry i did have a question uh so
uh a priori like making
making it to the outer distribution data
has more missing directions doesn't
actually make things worse it's like
if it's it's having more direction more
fraction
of the directions being missing kind of
like
yeah yeah it's like the fraction that
matters
and then the other interesting component
which is actually what we'll use for
fixing this so we can't change this
fraction much because we're given the
training data and we are given b naught
like we're given the pre-trained model
but this other quantity is actually
interesting
so this quantity so it has this slightly
complicated form maybe but basic
intuitively it measures the alignment
error so v star is your perfect head so
recall that the ground truth is v star
and b star so v star is the ground truth
perfect head and v naught is what you
initialize so phi over here measures how
far v naught is from v star so if you
initialize v star perfectly and let's
say we did one update like b star is not
going to change if you had initialized
that b star because v star and b star
together already fit your data and this
is the square law so there's no margin
and all of that to think about so if
you're if you're initialized perfectly
everything is good but you're not
initialized perfectly you're doing
random initialization and so the quality
that matters here is how far your random
head v naught
how how close it is to v star
so the farther uh your fee is sorry the
farther v naught is the larger phase and
your o d error could be higher
so basically because if b is a lot
farther from b star then you know b will
also change a lot to accommodate this
father v while doing gradient updates
so if you want to combine them or put
them together in this and uh what we
find is that for so for all steps in
fine tuning so for every t
we see that
as you approach the perfect pre-training
representation the od error of linear
programming versus uh or the error of
fine tuning approaches zero so lp does
much better than fine tuning as your
pre-trained model goes towards the best
pre-trained model
and under the conditions that the
principal angle um sorry this is b star
here between s and b star and between
star and b star is nonzero so these are
just making sure that you know you're
not missing like there are directions
that you are missing out so as long as
that happens then you are in the
situation that linear probing does much
better than fine tuning or d
whereas id error which is just measuring
on the subspace for which you have
training data you can you we can prove
that fine tuning always does better even
if b naught is far from b star
fine-tuning especially when b naught is
apart from b star fine tuning that's
better if both b naught is equal to b
star both perform the same but fine
tuning is always better
never worse
and the tool about how we kind of obtain
the result is basically to leverage some
kind of invariant that shows how v and v
are related throughout the process of
fine tuning so we have a like you can
basically write out an equation for what
v and b look like at every time step and
that that basically shows that if v is
very far then your b will also end up
changing a lot to keep that invariant
whereas if v was close to v star then
your b won't change much because that
invariant has to be preserved
so really crucial thing that comes up is
that the way you initialize the linear
head plays an important role through
this invariance that is held in the
process of fine tuning
and so this allows us to like not worry
about exactly non-convex dynamics and
stuff and we just like you know look at
the invariants to get a sense of what b
and b are
we all skip this in the interest of time
so that's basically a similar intuition
and so to summarize a fine tuning has
worse od performance when the
pre-trained features are good or this
epsilon is small and the distribution
shift is large and this is what we saw
in practice as well but there are more
missing directions in training data
and this occurs throughout the process
of fine tuning and so early stopping
like even more aggressive early stopping
won't fix this problem you will still
like each time you make any update to
the features you can actually find that
worst case it's going to
affect your od performance because your
head is randomly initialized
within distribution fine tuning is
always better or equal
so now hopefully this i think some ideas
are already coming up but what kind of
theory solution would this say
so how do we get the best of both worlds
so why does fine tuning do better in
distribution that's for the simple
reason that your pre-trained features
might not be perfect so it may not be
linearly separable and so changing the
features does give you more leverage to
actually get good performance in
distribution so especially if you have
imperfect pre-trained features this is
crucial
but why does it do worse out of
distribution is because the features can
change a lot to accommodate the randomly
initialized linear head and that's what
came up in those invariants that we had
for the gradient flow equation
but if we stare at these two things like
the natural thing to think about is we
actually only need to change the
features to fit your training data we
don't need to change the features to
accommodate this head so changing
features is fine as long as you're
changing it in a meaningful way
so can we refine these features without
distorting them too much and that would
probably give us the best of both worlds
um and so the idea here is that we first
do linear probing
so we learn the best possibly in our
head that we could have without changing
the features
and now we only but now we might not fit
the data perfectly because the features
were not perfectly linearly separable
but now let's refine the features but
we'll do so with this linear headers
initialization
because we don't want to simply change
the features to accommodate a random
linear head
so what we do here is like you first do
linear probing and then we refine the
features so the features separate out a
little more to accommodate these um
this linear head so in the process we
have still kept the overd performance
because the linear head hasn't changed
much but the features have changed a
little bit and so that enables you to
get better margin and better performance
in distribution as well
so that leads us to this lpft method i
guess we didn't get a better name um is
you first do linear probing and then do
fine tuning
and so we can actually prove that linear
probing this method does better or
dominates both linear probing and fine
tuning at least when the features are
perfect and the features are not perfect
a little more involved in like proving
things but in general the idea is that
this process enables us to make changes
to the features that are only actually
matter as opposed to features that
change simply because they're
accommodating the randomly initialized
head
yeah what do you mean
like if b naught is b star so it's
slightly trivial but at least you can
prove in that case when b naught is not
equal to b stars becomes a little more
involved um
for proving that it dominates both yeah
but it's subsumed
not necessarily i mean it doesn't have
to subsume like even if it doesn't like
linear problems will do better if those
directions are more likely like i mean
you pay more attention to unseen
directions
you'd
um
so these are the results in the same
data sets as before so if you look at
lpft uh which is this kind of just a
very small tweak to this process so what
we find is in distribution we actually
in fact do better uh probably because um
even in distribution like this is
offering an additional regularization
and so that does preserve more of the
pre-training information that helps in
distribution as well and it definitely
helps out of distribution and so
you can see that it obtains the best of
both worlds and this was kind of
interesting because it's really a very
small tweak to the process and in fact
we found some blog posts that said that
this is works better or something so
this is definitely not like a very novel
idea but it's something that people
weren't doing and they find that just a
small change to the way you fine-tune
can improve your in distribution and out
of distribution performance
you get up to about like 10 percent
over find no over the vanilla fine
tuning without doing without
compromising in distribution at all
yeah
is the
weights of the linear head changing at
all during the second time
it doesn't matter too much but yes we do
change the
head too yeah but in exactly the change
by very small amount
and so just to you know dive into the
results a little bit more so these are
the distribution accuracy so it's not
perfect it's not always domination this
fmow is like a data set which is we were
only using mostly imagined pre-trained
models and fmow is like slightly far
from imagenet pre-trained models so the
features are not that great and so in
this case we actually see lpft does
worse than fine-tuning um
but on most other data sets it does um
better
and out of distribution it does better
than other methods
okay so we also did dug into this a
little bit more and we did see that you
know the
intuition that in distribution features
change more than out of distribution
features at least in l2 distance does
happen when we do vanilla fine tuning so
it is true that there is some kind of
distortion because of that
and when we do lpft we find that in
distribution features now change in
order of magnitude less than what they
were changing when we did vanilla fine
tuning so just by fixing the linear head
initially we make the features change a
lot less even though we're running the
same gradient procedure
um
okay
so so just to summarize this part we
find that pre-trained models like you
know give a large improvement in
accuracy which is kind of interesting
and we don't understand totally why yet
but also how we find you know use these
models is kind of key and you know lpft
is just a starting point to even prove
as a proof of concept that there is
stuff that we can do to like get better
than what we currently have
and in fact in nlp like people have been
exploring this kind of lightweight fine
tuning but you only change a few
parameters or something like that and
again people typically do that for
saving computational costs but even
there the similar idea holds and we
improve robustness but perhaps a similar
reason that the features change less if
fewer things are changing and that helps
um
and in this whole discussion we have
assumed linear networks and two layers
and all of that and like so maybe that
only allows us to make a simple change
but perhaps we can get much more insight
and much uh you know more advanced
changes if we actually try to analyze
what happens with non-linearities and
deeper networks
um
and yeah so that might you know open up
a broader set of adaptation procedures
to actually think about like what is the
optimal adaptation procedure
and of course like you know i said in
the talk like there are several moving
pieces when we think about this whole
transfer learning or pre-training
setting in this talk we only talked
about adaptation procedure but like all
of these questions and how especially
pre-training and adaptation interact and
what is the right pre-training procedure
like someone asked like why does
representation learning work and like
what is the right objectives and people
have been coming up with new and new
objectives um in like you know
empirically but we don't have a good
theoretical handle on any of them and
how all of these components interact
together at the end of the day these are
all like open questions of course
and
okay so i have few minutes i'll maybe
flash each slide so with a little couple
of uh results in supervised learning
that i'll maybe focus on observation so
that people in the room here can
actually figure out why and what's
happening
so this is a pretty interesting
observation we had in this paper and you
know we called this accuracy on the line
so what we find is that if you plot in
distribution accuracy versus out of
distribution accuracy
strangely across many different model
architectures they all lie on this same
line with a particular transformation
so there is some very intriguing
structure in both the distribution shift
as well as like how the models learn
that causes this observation where like
in distribution accuracy perfectly
predicts out of distribution accuracy
like in for example if each model was
doing something different like we should
have been able to see that they
extrapolate out of distribution
differently right but for some reason
there is something very universal about
how all of these things use the data and
of course the data distribution the
shift itself that causes this
observation and we don't have any uh you
know insights into this
and the related thing we found is that
it doesn't just have to be accuracy if
we take a few models and look at how
much they disagree with each other we
see that the disagreement also follows a
similar trend so if you look at how much
models agree on one distribution versus
another distribution shift that also
perfectly predicts
what happens uh out of distribution
so this is practically useful because
this agreement doesn't need labels and
so you know
that it is useful from a robustness
perspective but it's also very
interesting from an understanding case
i don't have the plot here but in the
paper we find that this slope matches
only for neural networks so in the
previous case we had in the accuracy
case all different like svms and k ns
and all of that also lie on this
particular line but in this agreement
case we find that only neural networks
disagree and rely on the same accuracy
line whereas different models they have
different slopes so somehow the neural
network matches the accuracy slope
whereas the other models they have
different slopes
so that shows something more fundamental
about why agreement between networks uh
actually follows accuracy much stronger
than other models which we don't have
any understanding about
um i'll skip this the other thing that i
think we you know which is quite
interesting is this simplicity bias
and um so if you try to understand like
you know usually in theory we assume
linear features gaussians and look at
trying to prove things and typically
neural networks do the right thing learn
max margin and so on
but if we actually have a more nuanced
setting where some features are more
simple or complex than the other so here
is a synthetic data set we created so we
have mnist which is much simpler than c4
so we created a new input by
concatenating the two
so the model if you're trying to like
label this it could either use mnist to
like generate its feature sorry to
generate its prediction or cfar
and ideally a model would use both right
because both are predictive
but if you look at actually what happens
so if we randomize the c far part and
look at the network's predictions you
see that the logics are almost identical
so we kept the same mnist and replaced
the c4 10 with like some other part like
some other class
the network's predictions are identical
so what this means is that the network
completely ignored whatever c410s
predictive component was and only looked
at mnist
and so if we randomize the mnist of
course we see that the logits change
quite a bit they actually like reflect
the fact that it's randomized completely
so this shows that you know both of
these plots together basically show that
the network completely ignored c4 and
only use the mnist part
and this is a bit troubling for me
because you know there are many
predictive features in the data set and
of course we want the model to at least
use everything and not completely ignore
some features
so we find that it's not really in that
sense it's not like the right max margin
solution because you know you get much
more signal and separation if you were
using both
right so if you're in the setting where
you have some linear some non-linear or
more complex features but actually not
in the case that neural networks do kind
of the right thing and learn the
separate maximal separation they
actually tend to ignore certain features
and this actually something we see
repeatedly in robustness for example
spurious correlations come up because of
this so if a model like looking at the
background is much easier than actually
learning the features of the object and
so if you had very good correlation with
just the background then the models are
going to use the background exclusively
and we have to completely change the
training process to make them learn
anything else
and again we don't have a complete
understanding of why this happens and
what we can do to fix it other than of
course you know data augmentation but
that's not that interesting um and not
that general so i think that's a pretty
interesting open question
and with that i want to thank so there's
a lot of other collaborators but like
the work that i spoke the most is work
with ananya robbie thank you and percy
and also and thank google and open
philanthropy for supporting a lot of
this work
yeah thanks
[Applause]
that
like what class of label do you give to
outside yeah so like suppose so this is
class one zero and this is class zero so
we give the label zero
so both yes it's basically like yeah you
just match on both features so both
features would have given you zero
independently but now we put them
together and see what the network learns
and we find that so the network could
have learned cpr if it had only c power
could have learnt eminence with that on
the mnist but both put together it
learns
and i guess the
main i feel that you could trace that
another way where it's actually good
that it it solves the problem in the
simplest way
yeah but the problem with that is in
most real world cases we don't like this
like we don't have a control on what
things could be predictive or not so
like why this is bad is say if you're
doing like calibration or like they're
trying to use network confidence right
so suppose a distribution shift happens
or something happens and then now your
cpa has changed your network should at
least detect that some features that
could have been useful are different now
you can't even detect that because the
network just completely assumes that
unimportant so in a setting where those
probably were the right features this is
quite problematic
thank you thank you
[Applause]
we have a break now